hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in the symposium
Agathon gives a rather rhetorically
constructed speech in which he makes
several important claims about the
nature of love particularly about love's
connection with beauty and with moral
goodness or virtue Socrates is going to
take all of those claims apart and show
Agathon to answer this question is
Agathon nobody's talking about the quick
answer is no he actually doesn't know
what he's talking about he's saying
things that are very plausible that
sound great that are arranged in such a
way as they could convince an audience
that's not paying very close attention
but ultimately they're not based on
truth and so there's this this important
interlude that takes place before
Socrates actually goes into his own
speech the one in which he's going to
talk about when he was a young man and
talking with this this elder you know
why is woman do to MA and he's going to
bring Agathon into dialogue with him and
Agathon's not really up to it before he
does that he's going to make a sort of
complaint and you know it's a little bit
questionable how ironic he's being at
this point and how serious he's being
and driving these points home to his
audience but I want to go through that
before we look at the argument that he
steers Agathon into that culminates in
Agathon saying I guess I didn't know
what I was talking about so Socrates
complaint in essence is that all the
speeches that have gone before him
haven't really been doing what they're
supposed to do this is a complaint that
the other people before him have done as
well including Agatha but Socrates has
slightly different grounds for this he
says that these speeches just talk about
attributes of things like virtue or
power and then they attribute these
things to love and they do so in a way
that's kind of you know fortuitous or
random or willy-nilly they're not really
about love as such instead they're just
saying things that sound really cool
sound really great and then there
they're saying love you know fits into
this somehow these these apply to love
Socrates contrast this to a different
approach like I put here what he thought
that everyone should be doing at least
that's what he claims this is where the
irony could enter him he thought that
everybody should be setting out in a
true and unvarnished unembellished
account someone that's not rhetorically
structured one that you know is not
bringing in all sorts of you know
eloquence or or you know the flowers of
rhetoric just lay it out just just the
facts and the facts themselves will be
enough to you know give you a good
speech and everybody understands what's
going on at that point
now the contrast between these is not
just between who uses art form and who
doesn't it's a deeper contrast between
those who engage in a form of flattery
which is what Socrates takes rhetoric as
well as other things like cosmetics and
cookery to be and those who are engaged
in seeking out the truth and
articulating the truth Socrates says
that all these other people have just
engaged in flattery of love they haven't
actually addressed what love is in its
essence in its truth so this is a pretty
big claim
and this is um you know not really good
manners at this point in a dinner party
Socrates also says if I'm going to give
a speech I'm going to have to give it in
the way that I'm accustomed to I can't
do this speech giving rhetorical sort of
thing that all of the rest of you are so
good at I'm just going to talk like an
ordinary person the way that I do you
know in the marketplace or he does the
same thing in the apology with the lock
words I have to speak in the way that
I'm used to doing so they then grant him
that and they say all right Socrates
talking you're accustomed way do the
thing that you do and instead of
actually giving a speech he says before
I do that let me clarify a few points
with Agathon who just gave his speech I
want to make sure that we're on exactly
the same page and of course he doesn't
think that they're on the same page and
this is precisely what he's going to ask
and I get that in the questions now it's
interesting to to point out that
Socrates is attempted to get into
dialectic with Agathon and a few other
points in the symposium and he's been
shut down because people know what
Socrates does and they're like look this
is supposed to be a fun party
everybody's supposed to be giving these
great speeches
don't let Socrates do that sort of thing
because if you do he's just gonna you
know engage in this endless conversation
that doesn't seem to go anywhere in this
case it is actually rather short and
sweet though so here's the dialectic
with Agatha Agatha just to remind
ourselves has given this wonderful
speech that had two main arguments to it
one was that love is beautiful and not
only beautiful but the most beautiful
love is also morally good or virtuous it
has virtue to the highest degree and
then he goes into a lot of other stuff
towards it turns the yeah Socrates is
going to contest this and here's how
Socrates is going to do it he's gonna
make an argument that's not actually a
particularly good argument then there is
a linchpin in there that things are
going to turn on where if Agathon was
better versed in dialectic if Agatha
actually knew his topic he could have
said wait a second you're you need to
clarify things here but he doesn't so
Socrates gets Agatha to agree that love
is always love of something it's not a
love of nothing this up here is very
important in English we express a
certain set of relations with this this
preposition off in Greek it's done in a
somewhat different way using key
structures in this and this it's the
genitive case and you know if you don't
know anything about case structure from
Greek or Latin or German and that's okay
suffice it to say there's endings that
signify a certain kind of relation now
it's not a necessarily simple relation
so the genitive in Greek or our
preposition of can express a number of
different ways in which the things on
either side are connected up with each
other talking about love of something
means loving something or in this case
since its eros desiring something right
Socrates will bring up a bunch of other
examples and say you know a father is
not just a father per se a father has to
be a father of somebody right not a
father nothing because if he's if he's
not a father of any but he's not
actually a father
in that case we have a somewhat
different sense going on here this is
where the the equivocation is gonna take
place a father you know for instance my
father is the father of me in the sense
that in some way he is my origin right
now of course we know what genetics and
the mother and all that sweetens are the
mother of me - right father and mother
together of me my origin and Greeks had
a genitive of origin we can also talk
about social roles right so you know
father can be not just a genetic thing
it can also be somebody who behaves
towards me as a father in fact I'm
adopted and when I talk about my father
typically the person that I mean is
my adopted father because he is behaved
towards being a certain way a certain
way that's structured by wolves that's
another way of using this up the father
of Greg Sadler is Anton Sadler right
that's a in this case actually a
different father than my original
genetic father but it's good for
illustrating this case these are
different senses of the term of or of
the Greek genitive that's being used
here so when Socrates gets Agathon to
agree to this love is always love of
something and then he gets them to
follow through with that love of
something involves a lack of what is
love because love is desire right you
love what you don't have so if I were to
say I love chocolate what that means is
I'd like to eat chocolate because I have
desire for it or I love I desire
sleeping sleeping in on you know
Saturday mornings or something like that
or a love watching Saturday morning
cartoons that means I want to do that I
want that sort of thing for me yeah you
know there's also a clarification that
has to take place here that I didn't put
on the board but it is important to
point out what about when we have
something and we say that we love it
well like I'm eating a chocolate bar oh
I love this chocolate right I am
enjoying the taste but I want that taste
to go on I want that taste to be
something available for me in the future
and I don't possess the future Yeah
right because I'm not you know I'm not
some sort of Divine Being who controls
all time and destiny so maybe that truck
that bar won't be there for me in the
future and if I eat it up right now it
sure isn't gonna be for me another
chocolate bar could be and you know so
on and so on he uses the examples of
health if you're healthy right now and
you say love health a desire health that
means that you want to remain healthy if
I'm rich and I want to go on being rich
I desire riches not because I not the
riches that I have currently right now
but the riches that I want to continue
to have in the future so all that said
we come back to this point love of
something involves a lack
what is locked a desire for what is
loved this is a key idea here now where
is it going to go from here yeah I guess
thumbin has agreed to these points
Agathon has also said love is of the
beautiful and the good some of the
evidence for love being beautiful is the
fact that love hangs around with the
beautiful for example the young and love
is good in all these different ways you
know you talked about forward virtues
there's an affinity there now what
Socrates is going to get Agathon to
agree to which son probably shouldn't
agree to is that love is of the
beautiful and good in the sense of this
desiring you know and that leads to this
love actually lacking the beautiful and
the good why does love desire the
beautiful not because love is beautiful
but because love lacks the beautiful why
does love desire the good because it
lacks the good so we can draw further
corollary then love is neither beautiful
nor good if it had goodness it wouldn't
be desiring that goodness that it
doesn't have same thing with the
beautiful so you know Agathon can be
steered into an assertion actually the
opposites love is actually ugly and love
is not good so you know
Agathon what were you talking about when
you said this that love is in fact
beautiful and good and Agatha has to
come to the point
conquered by dialectic where he says I
guess I didn't know what I was saying I
was asserting something and now that I
look at it more closely which is what
dialectic actually does look at it more
closely I realized that I was mistaken
now there are some flaws to this as
we've pointed out but this is going to
be a very important turning point in the
argument